he was the father of fascism the
iron-fisted dictator who ruled Italy for
more than two decades during that time
he plunged his country into disaster
forming an alliance with Adolf Hitler
and bringing the wrath of the world and
his own people upon him in the end his
own citizens expressed their own
ruthless verdict on the man who called
himself he'll do che in this week's
biographic s-- we track the life and the
death of benito mussolini Benito L milk
array Andrea Mussolini was born on the
29th of July 1883 in a small village
near the northern Italian town of Preta
Pio in the province of Forli his father
Alessandro was a blacksmith and an
atheist who was heavily involved in
socialist politics while his mother Rosa
was a devout Roman Catholic school
teacher with his parents divergent
beliefs the young Mussolini was raised
to put his faith in both Karl Marx and
the Pope his mother took him to Mass
several times a week while his father
dragged him to the pub to learn from his
socialist friends from the start benito
proved to be an aggressive and
rebellious child in later life he
recalled I was not a good boy I was I
believe unruly by the time he was 8
Mussolini was spending long hours
helping his father in the furnace here
he would listen to Alessandro socialist
ideas and these were to mold his future
philosophy but the boys heart was with
his mother he feared displeasing her yet
this did not curb his wayward tendencies
by the time he was 9 Rosa had become so
exasperated with Benito that she sent
him to a school run by a Roman Catholic
monks in order to instill some
much-needed discipline but the defiance
Benito chafed at the strict discipline
and his behavior became even worse he
got into a number of fights and was
eventually expelled when he took on one
of the monks Rosa
nel sent her wayward son to a less
strict school place at a home this
though it did nothing to improve his
behavior and before long he was expelled
this time for threatening and other
students with a knife his exasperated
mother managed to find a third school
where he managed to see out his
schooling at the age of 17 Benito
completed
is ten years of compulsory schooling his
name a couple assurance over that time
work not really academic rather he
learned how to play the trombone and
speak in public
however despite his poor academic record
in 1901 he qualified as a school teacher
but he soon discovered that teaching did
not suit him he was far more interested
in the two passions that he had
inherited from his father socialism and
womanizing the eighteen-year-old Veneto
was a strong handsome man with a
forceful personality and a certain
charisma he easily drew the attention of
young women often the wives of other men
there's often resulted in him having
fistfights with people's husbands after
less than a year Mussolini had lost his
teaching job after getting into a
violent argument with no money and very
little prospects he moved to Switzerland
he worked in a succession of manual jobs
to support himself within a short time
he had attached himself to a group of
Marxists he also joined a trade union
and began attending rival political
rallies where he would heckle the
speaker and start fights with those in
the crowd as a result of these political
agitations benito was arrested and
deported back to Italy several times but
each time he returned to Switzerland
more determined than ever to keep
stirring the political pot Mussolini's
struggled to make ends meet in
Switzerland on one occasion he accosted
two elderly women on the street and
stole food from them in his 1928
autobiography he related that if the
women had struggles he would have
strangled them in 1904 he returned to
Italy and he joins the Italian Arnie
he served out his compulsory 18 months
ten months into his military service
Mussolini's beloved mother Rosa she died
distraught benito later called this the
greatest sorrow of his life he was
discharged from the Army in September of
1906 he had clearly not learned
discipline while in his country service
as his life now revolved around drinking
womanizing and fighting
[Music]
he managed to gain employment as a
teacher again with a succession of
temporary contracts during this period
prior to the first world war
Mussolini's moral character deteriorated
as his socialist ardor increased he
wrote for and edited several socialist
newspapers running against the
government's the democratic system the
middle classes and the church in one
pamphlet entitled God does not exist
he wrote that priests were black
microbes who are as fatal to mankind as
tuberculosis germs when Italy entered in
a war against Libya in 1911 Mussolini
led the internal criticism against the
government's actions through his
newspaper writings his outspoken
opposition led to his arrest and a
five-month imprisonment yet his fist
shaking public opposition to the
government had also gone at the
attention of the country's top socialist
leaders who looked on admiring Li the
young Benito Mussolini was viewed by
them as a rising star of the left in
December of 1912 shortly after his
released from prison Benito was
appointed editor of the country's
national socialist newspaper called
Avanti it was a natural fit and within
six months his firebrand style of
journalism had increased the paper's
readership fivefold
he now had a national forum with which
to err is for use
when war broke out in 1914 Mussolini
held firm non-interventionist views he
saw war as anti-socialist as it pitted
the working classes of one nation
against those of another within months
though he had changed his view he now
saw war as an opportunity for revolution
he now used his voice through the pages
of Avanti to call on the young men of
Italy to join the army
Mussolini's about-face on the war
situation put him at odds with more
moderate socialist leaders and resulted
in his expulsion from the party and the
loss of his head a chef of the paper
defiantly he started his own newspaper
ill populo Italia or the people of Italy
of this paper ran continuously from
November 1914 until Mussolini's removal
from power 29 years later in his first
editorial he proclaimed the famous line
blood alone moves the wheels of history
around this same time Mussolini founded
his first political party the fasi of
revolutionary action this was soon
simply known as the fascist party the
main Allied powers Britain and France
supported Mussolini seeing him as a key
to getting Italy more involved in the
war effort
they provided much needed financial
support to the new party the British
Secret Service even paid Mussolini a
wage of 100 pounds per week in July of
1915 Italy signed the Treaty of London
committing itself to fighting alongside
the Allies against Germany but Italy's
war soon became a fiasco
it was plagued by poorly trained and
inexperienced officers and unwilling
belligerent conscripts they became
bogged down in a battle of attrition
against austria-hungary by the time it
was all over more than 650,000 Italians
were dead half a million were missing
and nearly a million were wounded
Rosellini himself rejoined the Army in
September of 1915 he attained the rank
of Corporal winning acclaim for his
bravery and devotion to his men On
February the 22nd 1917 he was in a
trench when one of his fellow soldiers
grenades exploded he was badly wounded
requiring numerous operations over the
course of the next month and then he was
sent home to recuperate was Alaniz
message now morphed from socialism and
the plight of the working man to
patriotism and the cause of ultra
nationalism
[Music]
during the post-war talks in Paris Italy
it was treated dismissively by the major
powers the territories that she had been
promised during the 1915 Treaty of
London were not handed over the Italian
Prime Minister Vittorio Alonso walked
out of the conference in total disgust
Orlando bore the brunt of the public
discontent and was soon removed from
office in the following elections
Mussolini's fascist party failed to win
a single seat his political rivals made
fun of this staging a mock funeral for
the party chief among his adversaries
worthy socialists seward won a third of
the seats in parliament and whom
mussolini was now firmly opposed to over
the next three years the political
situation in Italy was extremely
unstable with four prime ministers and
coalition governments none of these was
able to yield any real power the country
was in a state of near Anarchy with
rampant inflation and unemployment
driving people to total despair
Mussolini's fascist stressed in they're
intimidating Blackshirts roamed through
the streets seeking out and beating up
socialists communists or anyone who they
didn't like the look off the police who
had sympathy for the fascists usually
stood by and let Mussolini's men get
away with it on May the 15th 1921
national elections were held this time
the fascists joined a coalition of
right-wing parties the National bloc and
they won 35 seats out of the total of
535 in the house of parliament
miscellany himself gained a seat in the
Chamber of Deputies he was now an
official member of the Italian
government realizing that he now needed
to broaden his base Mussolini did an
about-face on a couple of his
underpinning principles he became both
pro monarchy and pro church but his
hatred of socialism that certainly
remains Mussolini renamed the party now
calling it the National fascist party
his reputation began to grow and he
became known as a man with the ability
to rule with a firm hands and restore
order amidst the chaos that Italy had
fallen into public opinion was actually
beginning to turn in his favor that
popularity was bolstered when
Mussolini's black shirts broke up a
socialist back strike in October of 1922
at a rally shortly thereafter Mussolini
declared in the speech that either the
government would hand over power to him
or he would seize it for himself and
this was no idle bluster with no sign of
capital
by the government Mussolini decided to
stage a coup by marching on Rome his
forces though they were no match for the
Italian army but still the Prime
Minister Luigi Factor offered Mussolini
a position in his government in order to
avoid conflict the offer was roundly
rejected and the fascists marched on the
capital the panicked prime minister
urged the king to allow him to use the
army to quash the rebellion the king
agreed but he quickly changed his mind
fearing that a civil war would break out
this enraged the prime minister who
ultimately resigns from his office the
twenty thousand fascists marching on the
Capitol stopped 20 miles north of the
city there off of them left off and
returned home the rest carried on with
Mussolini himself joining them as
various points to have his photo taken
at the front of the line but with the
rain pouring down he was content to
leave the heavy marching to others and
took an express train and Rome the king
who secretly admired Mussolini now tried
to placate him by offering him a
governmental role what Cellini though he
would consider nothing but the prime
ministership eventually the King offered
him in the position by age 39 Mussolini
had become Prime Minister not through
violent revolution but through threat
bluster and unequivocal demands in the
wake of his victory ecstatic fascists
roamed the streets in search of
downhearted Socialists that they could
terrorize
Mussolini was now both Prime Minister
and foreign minister but his government
was very much a majority in the house of
parliament this forced him to work
within the confines of democracy which
left him at the mercy of the majority
coalition this though it was not a
situation that the power-hungry autocrat
would tolerate for very long within
eight weeks of assuming office Mussolini
formed the fascist Grand Council the
grand council acted as a conduit between
the fascists and the Chamber of Deputies
filled with his hand-picked appointees
it was in effect a mouthpiece for
Mussolini which effectively lessens the
power of Parliament to act in 1923 the
grand council passed a law that rigged
the electoral system to ensure that the
fascists gained a sizable majority in
the next election when the election was
held the following April the fascists
won 374 of the 535 seats
this new law had certainly helped them
gain the 70% majority but so did the
vigilance presence of Mussolini's black
chefs who coerced the public to vote for
the fascists in addition opposition
party meetings were broken up and the
candidates were beaten in the wake of
this overwhelming electoral victory
socialist leader Giacomo Matteotti
openly denounced the fascists and their
leader eleven days later Matt iottie was
assassinated this led to nationwide
protests against Mussolini and his party
of thugs with many people calling on the
King to depose the prime minister for
his part Mussolini pled innocence and
acted shocked and revolted by the murder
he did his best to distance himself from
the crime still politicians from all
parties responded by withdrawing from
Parliament in an effort to force
miscellanies ejection from office but
the King refused to get rid of Mussolini
in a vote of confidence On January the
3rd 1925 few of the Prime Minister's
opponents showed up ever the opportunist
he now took the opportunity to cement
his absolute authority he declared that
only the fascists could provide
stability in the country and it would be
achieved through dictatorship
[Music]
as Mussolini's propaganda machine
infiltrated every area of Italy a cult
of personality develops around him
people considered him to be a genius man
of action but one with a common touch
when things went well it was all thanks
to old Dikshit the leader however when
things went wrong it was never his fault
he was a mesmerizing speaker he used
facial expressions and gestures to
capture and then for all his audience he
stood at only 5 foot 6 inches and liked
to dress in striped trousers and shirts
with butterfly collars he was not a well
man physically suffering from ulcers and
stomach upsets his health problems
forced him to give up smoking and
drinking beginning to lose his hair in
his late 20s he took to shaving his hat
he was also short-sighted but too vain
to wear glasses
Mussolini spent the next two years
dismantling democracy in Italy and
establishing his own totalitarian regime
during that time he instilled three key
messages into the public consciousness
believe obey and fight this message
gained widespread approval even many
former socialists now turn to fascism
the firm hands of the state was seen as
the only solution to the country's woes
all forms of criticism of the state were
banned and opposition parties were
disbanded Mussolini himself was
answerable only to the king spies were
everywhere eager to report to the
authorities anyone who spoke or acted
against the state during the 1920s the
fascists have made modest improvements
in the Italian economy however all of
this was overturned with the global
depression that followed the Wall Street
Crash in October of 1929
once again the country went into a state
of economic chaos Mussolini responded by
embarking on foreign invasions during
the 1930s he sent armies into Lydia
Ethiopia and Spain Italy's invasion of
Ethiopia began in 1935 and resulted in a
devastating occupation that would
continue until 1941 when the British
Army forced the Italians out during that
time it has been estimated that 8% of
Ethiopia's population was put to death
Mussolini ordered the female populations
of entire towns be wiped out if he
Opie's leader Haile Selassie was forced
to flee to England where he petitions
the United Nations this infuriated
Mussolini and sent him into the arms of
a neighboring dictator by the name of
Adolf Hitler
on may the 22nd 1939 Hitler and
Mussolini signed a pact of Steel
this meant that they promised to come to
each other's aid in the event of war
less than four months later Germany
invaded Poland igniting World War two
Mussolini proved erratic in his response
to the prospect of fighting a European
war alongside the Nazis on the very day
that Germany invaded Poland whistle
Eenie announced to his cabinet that he
had decided not to fulfill his
obligation from the pact of Steel on the
basis that Germany had signed a
non-aggression pact with the Soviet
Union an act that violated the providers
of the pact the truth was that Mussolini
had absolutely no confidence in his
country's readiness for war despite his
announcement to his cabinet mursaleen II
continued to put up a pretence of
support for Hitler however in private he
spoke of joining the British and French
coalition finally On June the 10th 1940
with the Nazis looking assured of an
easy victory over the French Mussolini
declared war on Britain and France
Italian troops were quickly sent to
France in order that Mussolini could
have some share in the spoils of victory
at the same time he mobilized forces
into Africa to attack British Holdings
their large-scale forces were sent into
Egypt while other divisions focused on
Greece at the same time Mussolini was
overseeing the air force as they joined
with the Nazi Luftwaffe in the Battle of
Britain in every theater the
ill-prepared Italian forces were driven
back or stalemated
this enraged Hitler who was forced to
send German troops in to save the
Italians by the beginning of 1942 it was
apparent that Italy was fighting a
losing war they were badly beaten in
Egypt at the Battle of Alamein and the
Allied invasion of French North Africa
pushed them further back on their heels
the Allied invasion of Sicily was the
final straw
Italy's complete defeat was only a
matter of time
[Music]
the country was in a state of emergency
there was no fuel so all the factories
were not working food was incredibly
scarce with widespread starvation
resulting the people were desperate and
they were furious in this climate
a massive march on Rome took place a
march against still Duke Shay bowing to
the will of the people
King Victor Emmanuel ordered Mussolini
to his palace where he informed him that
he was removing him from office guards
then came in arrested Mussolini and took
him into custody the new Italian Prime
Minister Pietro Badoglio was intent on
breaking the alliance with Germany and
signing an armistice with the Allies
however in order to stall for time he
kept up the ruse of an alliance with
Hitler and surprisingly when Hitler
learns that the new ruler had signed an
armistice on September the 3rd in 1943
he was furious he ordered a full-scale
invasion of his former ally Nazi forces
used blitzkrieg tactics to storm and
capture Rome forcing the king and Prime
Minister to flee the city some elements
of the Italian army attempted to resist
but many of them simply threw down their
arms and surrendered meanwhile Mussolini
was being held at a resort turned prison
in the Alps he knew the situation was
chaotic that was surprised to see german
paratroopers landing right outside of
his cell window the Germans quickly
overpowered the guards and made their
way into Mussolini's cell while one of
them said elder J the Fuhrer has sent me
to set you free
Mussolini was taken to Hitler's East
Prussia headquarters at the genuinely
admired Mussolini and considered him a
great influence on his own career but he
was disappointed to see the man before
him all of Mussolini's will to continue
the fascist struggle had deserted him
the Fuehrer was dumbfounded when
Mussolini asked if he could be permitted
to retire from public life Hitler would
have none of it he installed Mussolini
as the puppet ruler of northern Italy
which was now in the hands of the Nazis
for the next 18 months Mussolini played
this role an impotent leader who ruled
over a people who hated him all the
while he was surrounded by armed Nazis
and the approaching allies with the
rioting well and truly on the wall
Mussolini tried to escape to Switzerland
on April the 27th 1945 just short of the
border he was intercepted by communists
who took him and his companions into
custody the following day they decided
to execute him along with his longtime
mistress
Clara Petacci after riddling the bodies
with bullets the Communists drove them
into Milan and dumped
in the middle of the town square for
hours the citizens of Milan took out
their emnity on the man who had led them
to disaster
his body was spat on stoned beaten and
finally strung up by the feet there the
body of the once revered leader was
subjected to the abuse of the crowd his
corpse was eventually thrown into an
unmarked grave so I really hope you
enjoyed their video if you did don't
forget to subscribe to this channel for
brand new biographies every Monday and
every Thursday also I've got another
channel it's called today I found out
it's sort of like bio graphics but way
more broad on that channel we get deep
into all sorts of details on all sorts
of interesting stuff check it out
through the link on the screen now but
if you're looking for something else to
watch right now why not check out a
biography from the archives over there
on the right or indeed today I found out
video and as always thank you for
watching